autre déplacement ce matin à trappes
philippe benassaya s'est rendu à
l'hôpital privé de l'ouest parisien en
compagnie de philippe juvin maire de la
garenne colombes et chef des urgences de
l'hôpital pompidou à paris une visite
pour le maire de bois d'arcy dans le
cadre de la campagne pour l'élection
législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription philippe benassaya le
candidat du parti les républicains
déplacements autour de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire par les élus locaux les
propos sont accueillis par patrick
jacques de dixmude la crise n'est pas
terminée il faut être sur le terrain
pour voir comment ça se passe et
l'hôpital de trappes et un hôpital
symbolique sur notre territoire qui
irrigue les villes qui sont tout autour
de trappes et je me devais d'être là
avec le philippe juvin le médecin bien
connue au niveau national pour faire le
tour un petit peu des hôpitaux et
notamment celui de trappes pour savoir
comment ça se passe et comment
comment gère cette crise sanitaire
au quotidien